we're series of small bio explained in
three minutes where I explain a concept
of multivalued your bio physics in less
than three minutes or so if you haven't
just subscribe to my channel hit that
subscribe button and I'm also present in
our negative me which is India's biggest
learning platform you can use my quote
every teen for giving 10% discount and
I'm also available there now we're going
to talk about circular dichroism in this
video and it's an absorption
spectroscopy method that relies on the
principle of differential light
absorption by the sample the way the
sample absorbs left and right circularly
polarized light is actually providing us
with many structural information about
that particular protein or for the
particular sample we are talking about
let's look at the inside of the circular
dichroism spectroscopy to understand how
the optics is arranged so first it is
light source a filter will a polarizer
quarter face plate followed by a sample
injection chamber and the detector for
detecting the light which is passing
through the sample so the light source
would first give rise to light which is
then going to pass through a filter V
forming a monochromatic light of a
single wavelength now that would pass
through a polarizer now the light which
is coming out of the filter which is
squeal is unpolarized but while it
passes through the polarizer it becomes
polarized but still it is linearly
polarized when it is passing through the
lambda by 4 face plate it is becoming a
circularly polarized light now the
sample is bombarded with the circular
polar polarized light and the sample
absorbs the circular polarized light in
a different way and after that the
transmitted light is detected by the
detector and from that the circular
dichroism spectra is created which would
give us important information about the
secondary structure of the protein so we
know that light is a electromagnetic
radiation which has an electric field
and a magnetic field and this electric
field and magnetic field vectors are
mutually perpendicular
to each other and also they're
perpendicular to the propagation
direction and that is how the transverse
wave walk right now here there are many
other type of polarization which are
shown like circular polarization or
elliptical polarization so what is so
different about circular or elliptical
polarized light now in order to
understand that let's see what happens
to a linearly polarized light when it
pass through a water faceplate so here
is a linear polarized light
now linear polarized light occurs when
the electrical field vector is
oscillating in a perpendicular manner in
only one plane okay now in case of
circularly polarized light the direction
of the electric field vector rotates
along the propagation direction and
while it is it is rotating the magnitude
remains the same but the direction is
changing with the propagation time right
so this is how a circularly polarized
light is generated but depending upon
the rotational direction either it is
clockwise or counterclockwise this term
- left circularly polarized light or
right circularly polarized light
now when the sample is absorbing the
left and right circularly polarized
light we can get information about the
concentration so it is very similar to
be a Lambert law so here the sample
which is optically active is absorbing a
left circularly polarized light let us
call this absorbing absorbance al and
the right circularly polarized light
let's call its absorbance a R now the
difference in absorbance uses very
important ideas about the secondary
structure now the Delta a or the
differential absorbance is going to be
proportional to the concentration and
the length of the cuvette and here the
epsilon terms are actually the molar
extinction coefficient for LCP and the
RCP light right now this molar
extinction coefficient is also known as
the molar circular dichroism visit
measure of the dichroism of a particular
sample and it is a function of the
wavelength so which light will
to use for detecting our sample it
really matters because it's a function
of the wavelength now the key aspect for
which the circular dichroism is popular
in protein biochemistry is the protein
secondary structure can be determined
using this technique not only that how
pH of the solvent how the temperature
can change the protein secondary
structure can also be determined more or
less protein folding kinetics and
unfolding responses can be determining
you can be determined using this
technique ligand or iron induce
structural changes are also possible to
detect but possible to be detected by
this technique now let's see how the
circular dichroism spectral look like
for a particular protein so there are
standard curves for example the spectra
for alpha Hill is looked like this or
pizza sheet and random coil are looking
like these now this is a standard format
now our protein of interest in this case
shown in yellow is having a spectrum
which is more close towards alpha helix
the conclusion is our protein of
interest is mostly comprising of alpha
helix structure and other structures are
not so much present in that particular
protein let's even second example here
our spectra look like this then we can
conclude that our protein of interest
has a lot of beta pleated sheet as a
component of its structure so we can
understand a lot about the secondary
structure of the protein from our die
circular dichroism spectra so I hope you
enjoyed this video if you liked this
video give a thumbs up don't forget to
Like share and sub